each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good morning everyone is my great
pleasure to welcome Tom Reston part tom
is a PhD candidate from UCSD and his
advisor is here Blair a very famous
cryptographer and he also collaborated
extensively with Stefan savage uchiko
know and all those folks that we're very
familiar with so Tom is interviewing
Drummle with the security and privacy
research group and the crypto research
group he's interviewing for both
researchers and postdocs position and
Tom is going to talk about his
dissertation work on how he has improved
the interface between systems and
cryptography thank you very much for
that kind introduction so it's great to
be up here in redmond talk about my work
in computer security and so the the
background of course for working
computer security is that it's
incredibly hard to get our complex
computing technologies of today to be
secure in the face of malicious users
and of course the the consequence of
having insecurities as we all know it
can be quite drastic weather its
criminals breaking into corporate or
other organizations data centers and
making off with data on hundreds of
millions of credit card accounts or
growing privacy concerns regarding the
fact that we're carrying smartphones
with us all over the place and these are
notifying third parties of our locations
or even some of my recent work
highlights how new technologies in this
case cloud computing can really give
rise to interesting new threats that we
need to consider and so to handle all
these you know to help us in building
more secure systems we really like to
have powerful tools and one such is
cryptography it's allows for example
encrypting a message so that can be sent
securely and privately over a insecure
public network and and the reason that
cryptography is is is so powerful it's
not necessarily what we set out to do so
much is how we ver
five that we've accomplished our goal
and hear what cryptographers do is make
use of a framework known as provable
security so the idea is that
cryptographer sits down and defines
precisely and mathematically the
algorithms involved the security goals
to what the tools are supposed to be
accomplishing and and quantifying the
adversarial resources that they expect
attackers to have whether it's be
running time or access to other
information and then our relative to
this abstract model where cryptographer
does is give a proof of security an
np-complete style reduction showing that
any attacker who can break the
cryptographic scheme well this implies
the ability to break some underlying
simpler primitive and what this
reduction does is actually give us a
very strong guarantee of security if we
make a judicious choice of our
underlying primitive for example basing
it on factoring large composite numbers
or some very thoroughly studied
primitives such as the AES block cipher
so then we get a very strong validation
tool we can use proofs to understand
that attackers at least if they're
working within this abstract model that
we've designed really have a very little
chance of breaking the cryptographic
mechanisms so what's the the catch well
the problem is really in the handoff
right because on one hand we have
systems with real implementations of
cryptographic protocols and and real
threats and on the other hand we have
cryptographers and using abstract models
to design and verify their their
algorithms and so the problem is if
there's any mismatches between these two
worlds then these mismatches can be
found and exploited by attackers so to
get back some of those examples on the
first slide right we have problems like
breaking into databases and and here the
cryptography graphic tools that we have
just aren't deployable due to legacy can
strengths and so this this leaves a
plaintext vulnerable location privacy
really isn't achievable by cryptography
alone of course you have other systems
related phenomenons like the fact that
we're using the internet and this
reveals our location already to third
parties and then there's you know more
subtle issues about using cryptography
in new environments that we're not
envisioned by designers and worse
implicit security critical assumptions
end up being invalidated so my work over
the last bunch of years has really been
about trying to tackle these problems
that that occur with the intersection of
cryptography and systems understanding
the types of gaps between three models
and in reality how these types of gaps
can be exploited by attackers and then
of course trying to figure out ways to
improve the situation and fix the
problems and so consequently I've taken
a pretty broad view of research working
both on understanding threats so really
this is just a nice way of saying
finding attacks against systems that are
using cryptography also building systems
so starting from scratch to create a
system that uses cryptography in some
broader system security context and then
also working on improving the
cryptographic theory and tools that we
have in order to make them more useful
for practical situations so what I'm
going to do in this talk is basically go
over a bunch of different projects at a
pretty high level and relatively quickly
talk about this issue of encrypting
credit card numbers in databases
problems related to the use of
randomness in cryptographic protocols
I'll look at building a security system
in the context of device tracking and
then I'll talk about my most recent work
at the end in the context of of cloud
computing and revealing new threats
there so let's say this is I'm going to
be going with things relatively quickly
and kind of high level courage you to
jump up and ask questions or interrupt
at any time can make this quite
interactive good okay so let me start
off by talking about this this this
problem with with credit card numbers
and the fact is that we just have
millions of databases out there that are
storing account information about people
and these databases you know so they're
storing names and also credit card
numbers for example and the fact is if
we want to encrypt these credit-card
numbers so that the if an attacker does
succeed in breaking into a system that
now if you would only have access to
cipher text as opposed to to the
plaintext credit card number data well
the fact is that our
existing traditional cryptographic tools
just aren't going to help us with a job
very well and this is for a relatively
simple reason say we want to use
something like a s a traditional block
cipher it's a map that uses the key to
encrypt applying text 100 went eight
bits to a ciphertext 128 bits and so if
we use this to encrypt a credit card
number well the result is that we get a
ciphertext that that is 128 bits and
there's no way to encode 128 bits into a
16 decimal digit number and so literally
the the cipher dexter's can't fit back
into the database in lieu of where the
plaintext was you can use a stream
cipher but it won't give you much
security so we'll i'll talk about that
in part in a minute so the problem is so
this is a kind of a gap right are
cryptic graphic tools the stream ciphers
block ciphers these things don't really
solve the the task at hand and and so in
practice we don't end up using
encryption database as much as we might
like and so the result is that when
criminals break into companies like TJ
maxx or even credit card processing
systems like Heartland Payment Systems
they end up making off with quite a bit
of data so we like to fix this situation
database schema somehow is used by all
these people
no I was giving an example but the point
is that there's a lot of software and
database systems that are built around
the idea that you have a 16 or 18 digit
credit card number and to use the
existing cryptographic mechanisms that
are actually secure for this setting
then you would have to redesign the
database and software around that creepy
guy from Exim because you can't just
replace in place the credit card number
with a ciphertext and so that yeah
method of entry stealing this data
solvent if the vast majority is still
will be a social engineering or trust or
rise that encryptions no more is no
better than an emotional that's you know
partly true the point is that we would
like to use encryption in this in this
setting too narrow and limit the focus
of what we need to protect right so
you're moving from having to protect the
database or multiple copies of a
database in various places on various
systems to having to protect the
cryptographic key right and so let it be
solved yeah that's the idea I'll talk
about how that happens to certain expand
we talk about details later in a minute
so the the suggestion actually for first
stream cipher what am i dancing here
right so the problem is that if you use
it stream cipher right you have to
you're going to encrypt with like a pad
basically right and so if you use the
same pad for multiple plain text so
where do you store the salts right is
the question is you've got other
information in those fields why not use
those
well the question becomes then you have
to ensure that all the information is
unique in every single field in the
database and so this becomes a usability
issue for the right so almost any
database is gonna have a unique ID
recheck cream store there should thank
you yeah so this is it you know these
are all great questions and I think that
the fact is I don't know all the details
about the deployment requirements in
these settings but when we talk to
people in industry who are deploying or
wanting to deploy credit card encryption
mechanisms they find that these these
there's too many constraints to do use
like things like stream ciphers and so
what they really want is a standalone
solution that you basically handed a
credit card number and under some
particular key that's easy to store and
like a hardware security module you get
back a credit card number that you can
then place into the database and the way
that's actually ended up being deployed
is that they're taking they actually
take credit card numbers when they first
enter a network for example and send it
off to hsm right away and get back
credit card number even before it ends
up landing in database so this provides
like global security no matter where the
credit card information ends up
appearing not just in a database but
throughout the whole network okay so the
solution that I basically just kind of
highlight a little bit is this idea that
we want to have what's called format
preserving encryption and the idea is
that we want to have encryption
mechanisms that can take for example
about credit card number unmap it under
a key now to a ciphertext that is also a
valid credit card number ok and this
replies for this particular example in
place replacement of the plain text with
the cipher text and the surrounding
systems that also use this credit card
number now can just treat it the cipher
text as before so how can we build such
a format preserve encryption scheme well
we could of course use a s and then just
truncate the output but this isn't going
to work right you've thrown away some
the values you need to decrypt the
ciphertext ok we can also of course use
something like electronic code book mode
this actually does allow for Matt
president
and for example what this would do is
associate to each plaintext digit
encryption of it right so you just this
this key is the table now and so to
encrypt a credit card number we just
replace literally two with with the
seven and three with four etc exactly
this is the same as the unsalted stream
cipher problem right so yeah of course
this isn't secure right because as soon
as you have one plain text ciphertext
pair you learn the codebook okay I'm
talking to two expert of an audience the
non cryptographers love this example so
anyway this is a horrible idea from a
security standpoint is the same as the
unsalted stream cipher what's that well
this is I could go through lots of
different attempts we could spend all
day talking about bad ideas okay so yeah
these things are these things are bad
straw man's right so what we really want
okay so we want a credit card a format
room encryption scheme for fret credit
card numbers but then when we came and
looked at this problem we said well why
are we restrict our attention to credit
card numbers we may also want to encrypt
say a valid postal address back to a
cipher text it's also chosen from from
the space of valid postal addresses for
some subset of all postal addresses or
maybe we want to apply this to some
formatted medical record and retrieve a
get a cipher text back there's also a
medical record and so what we say is
well actually maybe we should actually
try and target a more general tool right
providing an encryption mechanism that
actually can preserve membership in say
any arbitrary regular language and this
is actually the the problem that we we
set out to solvent and did solve so let
me just tell you a bit at a high level
about what we did we provided the first
formal cryptographic in modern
cryptographic treatment of the format
preserving encryption problem this means
defining what it means to have a scheme
providing security notions for example
resistance to message recovery tax we
don't want people from a bunch of from a
cipher text field recover the the credit
card number or other information and
then we provide practical constructions
but during this formalization actually
allowed us to take advantage of quite a
bit of cryptographic theory and also a
few related to for example ranking of
regular languages and so just to give a
flavor of what the proposed solution
looks like least for the specific case
of credit card numbers not for an
arbitrary language for credit cards well
we end up using a modified variants of
Luger a cough or fiesel networks and so
the idea is you take a 16-digit credit
card split in two sides and run the
right half through a s and now you have
a 128-bit value that you can encode as a
as a number and you add this mod 10 to
the 8th with the left hand side and you
get the right half output and you just
drop down the right hand side to the
left hand side and the point is this
round now is invertible so we can go
backwards through this and then we can
do many rounds of this to achieve
security and and provable security so we
can show that for any adverse tray for
example that's trying to break our
scheme in terms of say message recovery
well then this is actually going to
imply the ability to break a s in some
non-trivial way and so the
contrapositive gives us a nice guarantee
of security that the form a perv
encryption scheme is as secure as a s
and this means that we haven't
introduced any problems in the
development for the FP scheme
right so in the in the general case
right you have to do with this
underlying problem of encrypting on any
arbitrary finite size finite set and so
for example if you have a prime ordered
set then this becomes problematic and so
there's a bunch of techniques I didn't
talk about to deal with this but for
that particular case you end up using a
actually relatively old technique called
psycho blocking actually dates back to
like the the 1910s or something in World
War one but that is you can iterate a
cipher that works on a slightly larger
domain to get back into a prime order
set with one that can be split evenly in
half for example hmm you have to do
something about the distribution yes
well yes and no so the you don't the
definitions and the scheme don't require
any knowledge of the distribution in
plain text of course if there's only one
plan text and you get a deterministic
encryption of that one plain text you
you know there's one plain tag so if the
in general if there's very low entropy
in terms of the plain text size and you
see lots of examples there could be
concerned that you are learning
information about partial information
about messages but in these in these it
we still have the security win here
because we're still encrypting it so you
you would have to have access to an
encryption box to actually check to see
so say you have some relatively small
set of potential plain texts that you
know occurred you'd still need to do
trial encryptions with the box to
actually check if the ciphertext matches
the one you have in hand and so this can
be handled by for example metering the
number of encryptions allowed you know
per second or something and you know
it's a concern but it's a database can
you just say oh well one that appears
most that's California
here's next mostest New York oh I see
what you're saying yeah so so in
deployments we of course suggest using
salts as well so these are actually
tweakable and encryption schemes what
they call it technically so what you can
do is not only put the message and and
encrypt in Turkey but you can actually
in sometimes you can salt via the other
elements and so that is an important way
to important help to deal with that type
of variation issue but its fundamental
in this case if you need deterministic
encryption which is what we need here to
achieve this legacy compatibility that
the industry people are asking for then
you have this concern about about small
message spaces so the this work we were
talking to people from various companies
when we were working on this and the
result is that there's a standard that's
been proposed to NIST based on on this
work and in fact some of these companies
are actually already deploying this
technology so Heartland Payment Systems
is one of the companies talk saw that
had problems before and they are
prototyping system based on FP being
offered by voltage so so they actually
do like this this functionality okay so
that was an example of a kind of
mismatch between cryptography and
systems there was at least simple state
right we didn't have the right type of
tools too yeah one thing before you move
on this place for it but when you say
this is to the first modern attempt
this sort of thing are you intentionally
dismissing propels hasty pudding oh yeah
so so well he didn't formalize format
preserving encryption right he
formalized having a arbitrary bit or a
bit oriented cipher right and he did it
by hand so the problem with hasty
pudding is I mean so it gives you
something that works on bit streams bit
strings of arbitrary size but not
something that works an arbitrary
formats and so there's an extra step to
actually try formats but it was very
commerce um I'm not saggy maybe he
described it as an on this site that
could it cooked in any form and put it
back exactly that four justices so
that's just how he didn't talk about
doing things like encrypting regular
languages I think at all so he does it
is a very flexible ciphered it's true
and recite the work extensively of
course the you know the the basically
recognized problem with with Hastings no
one looked at it in terms of security so
no one knows if it's secure because it
was designed by hand whereas with these
types of schemes you can take advantage
of the analysis of a yes that's you know
been going on for the last ten years and
is ongoing okay so let me move on to
talk about a second problem which is the
use of randomization in cryptographic
algorithms and and how this causes
problems in practical settings so just
as a bit of background you know we have
modern public key encryption schemes is
a good example that I'll keep coming
back to this allows generating a public
key secret key pair and you know
distributing the public key so others
can encrypt messages so that only the
personal asst your key can decrypt but
the point is that many or the goal now
for modern public key encryption schemes
is that they are randomized which is
that which means that the encryption
mechanism not only takes the message in
the public key but also takes a string
of random bits or bits that are should
be choosing uniformly at random from
from the set of all such bit strings and
the reason for this is that it provides
a stronger security in some applications
so for example if we're communicating
between one party another and we and we
have an average trait that's seeing some
of the ciphertext going by
in the adversary can't even tell if the
same message was encrypted twice and so
this can be important in certain
contexts so in theory of course we can
just assume that we have access to some
algorithm that samples you know this
value are at random but in practice we
have to implement this somehow and so
what's done typically is using a random
number generator so software based
around number generators for example you
know measure a certain unpredictable
events like keyboard press is from the
user or mouse movements and then try to
extract from these these measurements a
string are that should be hopefully
should be uniformly uniform at random
from an average trace point of view but
the problem is of course that there's
been a long line of work showing that
Ram number generators are really hard to
get right so this ends up with problems
that are his exposed attackers are
repeated or even predictable in the
worst case so there's this famous
example at least in this community
should be pretty well known about the
Debian openssl bug where they commented
out a couple lines of code and the
source base and these were the lines of
code they're actually responsible for
adding measurements to the random number
generator and so you ended up with a
very small set of possible are values
that are predictable to an adversaries
point of view this is true so so yeah of
course if you have keys that are
generated with bad randomest your host I
mean I think there's a distinction here
between and then one that that's
important here is that in between
frequent and infrequent operations so if
you're generating key you kind of
generated the public you see UK parrot
once for a long time but then every time
you encrypt a new message you need new
randomness constantly and so it seems
intrinsically more difficult I mean you
need more randomness to deal with the
problem of generating remnants for
message encryption you need it in a
variety of contexts where as you can at
least the ideal case sit down with and
generate the public use you compare it
once and then distribute the public key
using the same underlying random number
so it's got a small Senate are right and
not only are your protocol random is
broken so are your Kings just ready yeah
and and and there's something
fundamental that we can't change crypto
to make up for that problem right if you
don't have any randoms anywhere well
cryptography doesn't work absolutely so
what we're going to it all you know to
lead in a little bit what I'm going to
deal with is one of these two problems
which is dealing with the routine
randomness and if you have good keys
then we'll show that you can do
something quite a bit better than what's
currently done with a bad routine
randomness let me tell you about another
place for my recent work where
randomness Ram number Jenner is kind of
failed this is the context of virtual
machines and the idea is that security
experts and and companies are
advertising the idea that you should do
browsing within a virtual machine and so
the idea is pretty straightforward so
you set up a guest operating system and
run say your Firefox or some other
application within it and then you can
take at this point a clean snapshot of
the of the virtual machine what is this
a it's a copy of the entire state
including active memory and persistent
storage and this snapshot then you can
reset to every time you want to do a
browsing session okay so with the idea
that now in one browsing session you
visit a bad site and you are have a
vulnerability exploited well then the
virtual machine ends up getting
compromised but the isolation guarantees
the hypervisor should ensure that the
host operating system remains virus free
and so next time you go surf and you
reset to your snapshot then well the
malware's gone and you have security a
new secure session so this has some very
tangible security benefits but some
recent work we show this actually causes
problems for cryptographic protocols and
it's because of RAM number generation
failures so the if you're in this
setting and you you know reset to your
virtual machine and then now visit a
secure website so use HTTPS then what
happens is the TLS clients on the
browser pics uses round number generator
to generate some secret randomness
that's then encrypted and sent over to
the sir
and then this this now shared secret is
used to bootstrap a secure session to do
to do your banking now the problem of
course not of course the problem we
found out is that if you then reset to
the snapshot and visit new website
that's using HTTPS you actually end up
the random number generated the same
values for the browser and so you end up
sending this secret value to the next
server you visit and this of course is a
problem because this is all the secret
data needed to decrypt a transcript of
the of the banking session this was an
abstract problem is the problem with
with with real browsers firefox and
chrome had this behavior and again the
the problem is that the ramp number
generation process is really being
undermined by this snapshotting and this
isn't limited just to browsers we also
looked at TLS servers and particularly
we looked at apache mod ssl and there if
you're running it multiple times from
the same snapshot then you end up and
you're using DSA mode then you can
actually end up stealing the secret key
from from the server and in general we
think that the this these what are the
first examples of what we're calling vm
reset vulnerabilities really seemed to
be a big you know the tip of the iceberg
so to speak and in problems here because
there's a lot of legacy software it's
being run in virtualized environments
and whether they deal with snapshot
incorrectly is an open question but back
to this story about driver animus well
is it easy
so with that's actually so that we
haven't worked on this so this brings up
you know two issues which I'll talk
about in this slide right you know one
is that you know we need to revisit the
design of energies in these applications
so there seems like in the short term
there could be a good fix which is just
that you you don't have Firefox for
example cash randomness up front and and
it just does it every time you do a new
HD wrist request whether in all
virtualized environments this is
actually giving you good new different
randomness each time you run from the
snapshot is an open question and
something we don't know and we think
actually fixing the problem in general
is can require more extensive changes
you're gonna have to revisit hypervisor
design understand that the random number
generators need to be backed up by
something from the hypervisor you the
hardware or or software based and also
have all your applications aware of the
fact they can't cash randomness for long
periods of time because this would still
allow this type of reset problem firefox
having read this it's a good question we
notified the vm m designers as well and
they said it was a firefox bug but you
know that the random number generator
after taking the snapshot into different
instantiations right to pick a snapshot
you can stand she ate it call jen ran
and then you
well that would be true if you had
hypervisor that gave you a ram number
generator in this case there what it's
not set up that way no no no no that
okay so there's there's two things here
if you have a hypervisor that's
providing a round number generator so
for example your place Deb random with
something the VMM is supplying the
randomness for then you would be ok i
think but this requires a change to some
of the virtual machine hypervisor design
if you just call dev random and rely on
the guest operating system to generate
30 minutes well the problem is dev
random gets rolled back with the
snapshot as well and so it's not
entirely clear that you are gonna get a
good randomness yeah no it's an open
question I don't know actually I mean it
seems like it depends on a lot of things
right what measurements they're taking
whether there's enough differential
entropy between one run to the next run
this is something we want to study and
measure to understand I mean to
conjecture I think having software-based
random number generators in the setting
inside the guest OS only it seems kind
of like doomed to failure it's at some
point but whether it's actually a
vulnerability or not is a question ok
you always reliably reset the snapshot
to the point afternoon
the usual
or I mean so so the way it works is the
if you drove back before that's cash
right yes yes yes so the way the way it
worked with Firefox for example is that
the RAM number generator is used at the
time the Firefox is booted up so if you
snap shot at any point after Firefox is
Ron so in the particular experiment
Firefox let it sit for a second took a
snapshot and then and then went back and
this is consistent behavior that the
same random Scott taken all the time if
you took a snapshot in the middle of it
booting up or something and then you get
inconsistent behavior but this is
unlikely to happen from a usage point of
view so now it will be epic
you drove back your ex kitchen before
this well oh really have a snapshot
Ranger yeah yeah it's I don't know if
there is a I mean one simple fix would
be to have an architectural like an
Intel instruction that gave you
randomness and then maybe you'd be okay
but this is totally circumventing the
hypervisor I mean only if you call right
so there's there's multiple layers of
problems he write the applications need
to be aware of the fact that they're
being taking having snapshots taking of
them and the fact is the way purposely
the way hypervisor designed is so that
applications don't need to be aware of
these things like snapshots right and
that's a functionality thing which is
allowing legacy compatible deployment of
systems and virtualized environments so
there's this tension between
functionality and security here and I
think this is as I was trying to say
before indicative of a broad set of
issues that I mean we're we're taking
all this legacy code we're throwing in
virtualized containers there's
fundamentally new things going on with
these virtualized containers right we're
rolling things back resetting we're
making copies duplicates and and launch
them off and this is all going to become
a bigger problem and so finding the so
to have a complete system solution is i
think is an open question and something
that means that i'm looking at but you
know i don't think there's a really a
quick fix that sound in any principle
sense there's a pretty easy for my
sister's perspective my neighbor is one
fairly easy trigger point which is on
so you force like a deal
an address change that's something these
applications are used so you still have
the modified yeah all the application I
could be the one I don't least there's a
point where you say you know you don't
have to introduce new event we just have
to introduce the knowledge into
developers that right when you see the
address change you go get her number as
well
so that that's going to be a significant
amount of work so you have to educate
all the developers here at Microsoft on
this right yeah yes and they're two
things right i mean basically and this
is funny because I when I was talking to
a to Chrome or Firefox one of the guys
they were saying look we're using best
practices for random number generation
in our code and so we should be fine and
I'm like well okay the problem is with
virtualization we're now we're going to
have to really rethink best practices
for a number generation usage and I mean
that's just the fact I think so that's a
whole host of issues that I'm not going
to talk about what I'm going to talk
about the next few slides is this kind
of somewhat embarrassing fact maybe that
that you know our cryptographic
operations in the face of you in this
repeat random it's like fall over
completely right session Keys get
revealed okay also secret keys for DSA
signature scheme get headaches you can
steal them from the server and so our
question that we the question that this
this work motivated in part was you know
can we make the cryptography more robust
to these type of failures of routine
randomness so to reiterate you know we
have kind of varying levels of
randomness right we have a proper energy
it's providing always fresh memnos we
have these settings like vm resets where
you get repeat usage of of randomness or
even have things like the debian openssl
debacle which you end up with a very set
of predictable values being output with
our traditional cryptographic mechanisms
basically they were designed in this
context where you assume good randomness
always and so you get strong security
guarantees given a good proper ramen
trainer but otherwise everything fails
and so our idea was like okay let's
let's fix this situation and we call
this hedged cryptography that we want
our cryptograph to operations our
routine cryptographic operations to be
as secure as possible in given whatever
randoms they're given so for example
with public key encryption when we get
good randomness we achieve our
traditional strong security strongest
security goals we get for example repeat
randomness given to our encryption
algorithm then we're not going to be
able to and provably so meet our
strongest security goals but what we'll
do is instead of failing completely will
achieve some weaker but still very
meaningful level of security and so for
example here you you're only going to
leak the Faculty of plaintext equality
which is something that randomization
requires to get rid of that that
and then if the the randomness is
predictable then will again get a
slightly degraded security level but
still very strong and and here that only
plan text quality gets leaked assuming
that there's sufficient entropy in your
message randomness pair combined so let
me just talk briefly about this this
this last case which is some sense the
hardest for public key encryption and if
we sit back and think for a second about
our encryption mechanism well there
actually always exists an attack against
public key encryption and it's just a
brute force attack that works as follows
right you you enumerate the set of all
possible messages and the set of all
possible our values and then you just
iterate doing trial encryptions over
each pair and then check to see if the
output ciphertext is equal to the target
one that you're given and if and if it
is then you know what the message of
that that target ciphertext is ok so
this always exists but it's not always
practical so of course if the the set of
messages or the set of randomness is
very large then then this is inefficient
and not gonna be tractable in practice
and so at a very high level what our
target for hedge public encryption is
that security a secure hedge public
encryption scheme basically mandates
that this attack is is in some sense the
best attack possible that any other
attack will essentially work only as
well as this brute force attack how can
we achieve such a thing well we have
this idea that we could if we could
design our encryption scheme to behave
like what's called a randomness
extractor then we would actually achieve
this school so random sex tractors are
these classic objects that have been
used quite extensively in computational
complexity they're used in context like
D randomization of randomized algorithms
and been studied extensively what do
they do well they're a map that uses a
seed s to map values from some large
domain to a smaller range but with
special properties so for example if you
choose any subset of the domain that's a
smaller but still large size then any
point shows randomly from the subset
actually gets mapped to a uniform point
in the range and so in particular
if we design if we just have our
encryption mechanism actually act as an
extractor so we choose our public key to
be such a seed then this properties of
the extractor basically makes it look
like if you have a message around its
chosen randomly from some some set of
mrs then the an output cybertek's given
to an adversary is just going to look
like a random randomly chosen ciphertext
and so you actually hide information
about the message so this approach has a
critical failing which is that we need
to be able to decrypt messages and
extractors are fundamentally compressing
objects to get these properties you need
to go from a large space down to a
smaller space so you're throwing away
some the information you would need to
to decrypt so we can circumvent this
actually using some new cryptographic
objects called Universal lossy trapdoor
functions and the idea is is actually at
a high level somewhat simple we have a
function now that actually there's two
different types of keys so you can
choose a normal key PK which has a
trapdoor associated to it and actually
maps to a set of a range of sufficient
size you can you can decrypt properly
but the same time there exists another
way of generating a key s such that the
encryption algorithm now works like an
extractor and so what it does is
actually only uses some relatively small
subset of the entire range to to map
values from d2 and moreover the point is
that these these public key and and s
values are indistinguishable so from an
attackers point of view he's given the
encryption of a mr and and the another
value either the PKS you can't
distinguish between the two so a lot of
well have been encrypted with this
extractor key s and so that means that
we get back to this place where we get
the nice properties from extractors that
they're hiding information about
sufficiently high min entropy inputs yes
seguin could you give us an intuition
for those nasty okay so that a high
level what's the motivation here that we
want to take advantage of any entropy in
the message space to make up for a lack
of entropy in the randomness and so we'd
like to basically take advantage of all
entropy in the mr in the message and the
randomest combine and extract that out
fully and so what you know extractors
been used in other cases where you
basically have some some set of measured
events right these are actually used in
in some sense for random number
generation and what they do is they take
any any inputs and they map it to an
output and it looks like a uniform point
ok but the fact is to do that to get
that property you need to have a smaller
set and so that comes the cryptographic
component it's actually design a
functional encryption scheme we need to
do something more clever and and that's
where this this notion of ltd f's comes
in these lossy trapped or functions
because they asked have two operating
modes when you actually use it in
practice use a public key that actually
maps to a set that's big enough to
decrypt from ok but when you're doing
your security proof you can then say
well from an adversaries point of you
can just imagine that this public he
behaves like an extractor and in it gets
this property that it's the output just
looks like a random point during the
security like Anna why can't well I mean
there's a lot of details but I'm sorry
saying what is it why does this creep
probably continue to
you proved the security property while
you're using it one mode and using this
reducing those so the point is right so
the key the key thing is this is this
last kind of mumbo-jumbo at the bottom
which is that from from if I hand your
cipher text and a key let's let's call
it D or something and now d is either a
public here s and you don't you can't
tell the difference so in the proof when
you take advantage of that fact to say
okay if we're encrypting a message in
regular world with public key you get
ciphertext it might as well from an
adversaries point of view been encrypted
with this this value s to see every
demonstration reasonably assume right
actually using this in practice it
really is a real boat right but the
point is that if you could if you can
distinguish between if you can learn
something about em then you're going to
violate we can show using these
reductions that you can you're violating
the fact that these two things are
indistinguishable which we prove and
under some complexity assumption like
well not factoring because we haven't
shown that relation here but something
like solving a discrete logs your cdh or
ddh i guess in this case decision to be
helmet so the point is if in the proof
you if you show this what you've shown
is that any attacker that does learn
message about em has is actually able to
do something hard and that's what the
proof is in depth so i was just giving
intuition about one of the steps of the
proof and trying to gloss over quickly
ok so we yeah there's proof stuff and
and and and then the the fact is that
you know we can take these ideas
basically oh good and and and we and we
moved and moving from this starting
point this is actually these
constructions are not practical but what
we showed is that we actually can do
practical framework for hedging a
variety of randomized primitives and i
won't won't talk about it but the fact
is you can just go and implement it and
it's incrementally deployable it's
backwards compatible yes
so in the end it's like doing two more H
Matt calls / RSA by itself or ours an
RSA based encryption scheme right yeah
yeah not the construction we're showing
but there's a simpler less
mathematically interesting construction
boat something that's very practically
interesting and so we implemented in the
openssl library and the takeaway is that
now what we we get is that we have
implementations of the cryptographic
tools that provide us nice defense in
depth right graceful degradation of
security in the face of bad randomness
right so if if some random is failure
occurs our crypto operations are no
longer image cumple fall over completely
but give you this graceful degradation
of security okay so we saw in the last
two examples right problems where we
identify some issue of practical concern
and dealt with it by modifying the
crypto okay and in the next in the next
example which is kind of systems
building a example we're going to see is
that while we can do a bunch of nations
and design with cryptography we're going
to see that this doesn't actually solve
the whole problem and so here it's gonna
become important to understand the role
of the crypto in a broader system
security context and in this context is
device tracking so let me tell you a bit
about device tracking systems the idea
is straightforward right you install on
your mobile computing device a tracking
client which is going to use the
internet to update a remote storage
service operated by some third-party
about the current whereabouts of your
device it could be the time the IP
address what wireless network you're
connected to and maybe other forensic
data like pictures taken with a webcam
and then the idea is that if it goes
missing or stolen the tracking client
should nevertheless keep updating the
storage service with this data and the
user excuse me can can you know excuse
me retrieve this data work with the
authorities and try to attempt recovery
of the device it's exactly like LoJack
yes boom so solo jack is a great example
of this and and the point is that
there's actually a big industry
surrounding the
products now and there's a lot of
companies offering them and they're all
competing on this engineering to ensure
the tracking succeeds in the face of
physical adversaries right so they so
this laptop has a LoJack client actually
in its bios for example to survive hard
days formats and that type of thing we
are interesting a different aspect of of
this problem which is the the privacy
issue right that's of course that these
tracking services are also as designed
tracking the legitimate owner when via
their devices and so from a
psychological acceptability standpoint
this this seems a bit uncomfortable and
so we pose this question that can we
provide a tracking service that at least
the tracking service provides the
functionality that's required in the
sense of tracking the the system after
it goes missing but at the same time
protects the privacy of the owner when
it's when it's in their hands and so of
course the the first idea how is that
we'd like to just encrypt this content
before sending it over to protect it
from from people at the remote storage
site that's being operated by other
parties and so we can do that but
there's two problems with this one is
that of course other users are going to
be making use of this remote storage
service and so there's going to be a big
database of anonymized encrypted content
and so the question is how do you
actually efficiently retrieve a
particular user's updates if by
definition you want this stuff to be
anonymous so we can actually solve that
using some fancier cryptography but I'm
not going to talk about so talk about
crypto let's put up this kind of
scary-looking flowchart but the idea
that you want provide mechanisms that
provide fast search over over encrypted
data and so allow the user to retrieve
his data efficiently without revealing
information about past locations there's
a second a problem here which is that ok
even if you do this all this fancy stuff
the the fact is that when you're talking
with the internet you're revealing your
IP address to the remote storage service
and yes it's a question that have
questions
their reason there were two problems no
third problem that once the bad guy gets
your device he also has your Christian
keys and can say right I lost my device
under your that it in the past that's a
great question yeah so are all the fancy
crypto is providing forward privacy so
as the as the device uses up encryption
keys it basically picks new ones in a
deterministic fashion but such that you
can't recover previous keys you can
think of that way yeah yeah it's like a
yes yeah it gets a little bit
complicated cuz we want to build in
things like a a cash on the side so that
you can cash the last few locations
inside the clients you have to encrypt
this and kind of randomized encryptions
before sending them off this type of
thing but yeah we dealt with that issue
is it assumed that I don't have some
home trusted store that I think I do
yeah right you want make it take
advantage of a third party service to to
provide the storage of your if I hope
you just or a key in order to match the
foot forward secrecy then I just encrypt
with that that key for the device third
party when you say home do you mean on
your laptop cuz I'm here right now and
my laptop is updating some you know I
mean I have some hey papi words yeah you
do use you so a floppy I don't have any
floppy so I'm computer question sorry I
you either safe in my house a smaller
than under David yes that's the exact
idea so we're going to neutralize the
client with some some small like an 80s
key and that's going to be used to
terminally generate more material that
we used to encrypt and index are our
updates the client needs access to those
those values and needs to send them off
okay and that that's the intuition
behind the cryptographic component
service is already a good party service
right so so that and that brings me to
the next point why is this point that
you're revealing IP address is
potentially damaging and the idea is
that there's there's partial information
leakage here that you can do based on
traffic analysis right so okay we send
an update now that it's totally
anonymous and encrypted from a
particular IP address in a particular
time we're sending it to remote storage
service and so this is what the remote
storage service fees now what you can do
is take this this IP address and this
already reveals the location right
because you can use a geolocation
service to identify where the IP address
is physically in the world and so okay
now you know it's a home residence right
and so the point is next time you see an
update from this home residence you have
a good guess that that person now return
to it for example and so well it's not
entire one percent damage like you're
not revealing everything all the time
and and you can hide to some extent in
crowds the fact is there is partial
information being leaked about locations
via just the faculty of an IP address
and so we set out to try and to solve
this issue as well right we don't want
to just rely on the crypto there's a
systems security issue here and so can
we can we deal with this mitigate this
threat of traffic analysis even beyond
what the crypto can provide okay so we
there's actually a long literature on on
inhibiting traffic analysis which oops
which revolves around doing Onion
Routing so the idea is used bounce your
packets off a just distributed randomly
chosen set of nodes to kind of longer
the source IP address and so we could
use this type of system as well but we
thought well maybe we should we actually
thought okay there's there's overheads
with these types of things like latency
and encode complexity and such and the
question was so we were motivated say
can we actually improve privacy from
traffic analysis in some sense for free
by using some decentralized storage
infrastructure to store updates and so
the idea is we ended up using what are
called distribute hash tables now these
are systems that are decentralized so
you have something like booze or azureus
which has millions of nodes in it and
it's being used for things like
BitTorrent and it provides a very simple
API that you can put data under some
index and then retrieve later that day
by providing an index and so what we
ended up doing is saying okay let's take
advantage of this decentralized
architecture so when we do all this
cryptographic work we also pick
cryptographically random indices ones
that can be recomputed later by the
owner but from an adversaries point of
view without the original key they just
look like random values and then when we
do a put we do a put under using that
random index and what this does is
actually ends up choosing a random node
to talk to in the architecture and so
the next time you do an update actually
chooses another node and the idea is
that now we've diluted trust across this
decentralized storage IRA structure for
free without having to use onion routing
and so even if some subset of the nodes
are compromised they well they only see
one if ever if that many updates is the
idea okay so with privacy systems of
course we were interested in seeing you
know is this actually deployed what
could people use this type of setup both
in the cryptographic side and and with
with the HTS and so we went ahead and
implemented and released a these
pictures were taken from our client with
a lot of fun playing out the webcam
there and we're very happy with the
results that quite a few people
downloaded it and and have been using it
and then maybe more importantly this
this work this idea of using dhts is a
security privacy tool picked up a bit of
steam and and there's been follow-up
work in the community about the efficacy
this idea of using using PhDs so okay
clients no no they took advantage of the
existing Govind DHT architecture yeah so
most of the client so so open the HD
might not be the best a realization of
this but we use it because it was
simplest to work with and it has I think
at the time it had suddenly 160 hundred
seventy nodes so from that point of view
yeah you may end up talking to all the
nodes at some point of the lifetime of
the client you're still achieving some
benefits in terms of privacy but it's
not going to be to the scale like if you
linked in with vuze or azureus where you
have millions of notes but we want to
use MV HD because it was it was simplest
to work with at the time and as a
prototype see people would actually be
able to use and would want to use this
their compromises in our prana stones in
the DHT
easy to create brett package really
wanted right that i'm asking a bit
welcome it that you would get to see
information about some IP addresses that
we're sending of things but it would be
randomly selected from among the modern
beset so right you get good information
that would you wouldn't be able to
target said what's happening right right
so some some portion of the updates you
can miss the compromised hopes right
from a particular client most of them
yeah that's the idea so if you had a
simple attack where you took over the
whole DHT then you're back to the fact
that you have encrypted anonymize la
update so you have a little bit of
privacy leakage but not not that much if
you have a DHT the resistible attacks
you get much stronger privacy
improvement against for these particular
traffic side-channel attacks yeah that's
the idea then you get stronger robbery
right and then on your honor of course
has its own issues about whether it's
secure all the time or not but right so
you could do both right you could route
the DHT puts across onion routes and
then you would get like you know the
most paranoid level of a privacy Evan or
something assuming all the components
are good
you only need to defeat them it only to
be private up to the point that it's
easier for somebody to just stick a
webcam outside your house and see right
get ready right right exactly and that
raises a good point there's there's
plenty of other ways that location
privacy can be violated by someone's
laptop right even so if you contact
gmail every time you sit down with your
laptop of course you're notifying Google
of all the locations you're visiting but
solving the location privacy in the
global sense is a much more at the
moment intractable problem so we're
trying to say just for the device
tracking component can you ensure that
we're not we're not doing anything
really help here because if the first
one with you touch is compromised you're
screwed either way but you choose a
different note each time so you get the
same type of guarantee you get from the
DHT that we're using well there's
another layer of potential yeah I mean
yeah that's actually a great point uh so
if you're if you're yeah you get the
same level guaranteed yeah yeah there's
a lot of details I'm glossing over the
DHT is that but this that's like a
pepper for example we have to do we have
to do replication as well to get
functionality the DHT so you actually
it's not just one note you talk if you
talk to three and then if if you
actually have to communicate with
multiple nodes for each put then you are
leaking over so you know there's a bunch
of Z test again is this really is this
less complex than tour because the other
the other reason you give for
superiority over and United mouse
latency which I can't imagine is an
issue here well so yeah it may not be an
issue a killer issue right you know one
thing to be perfectly frank your's is
easier to work with open DHT when we're
implementing it than to work with torah
it's a big codebase we want to have a
very small client to fit in something
like a bios at some point the the
latency issues I mean you have to
complete the circuit right so yeah and
generally may not be a killer issue but
the idea is we want to we wanted to
experiment with this DHD and get the it
for free and then you don't have to have
tour and rely on other people's tour
nodes and all the security issues there
so in the end it's going to be a choice
for deployment right if you want to use
both
one or the other it's it's up to the the
people who end up designing the the
system she really just need to send one
packet in one direction you don't really
need to establish it right right so you
can use a mix router or something i can
get raised offline if ever there was a
week utilize you back negotiation I'm
sorry singing but here that location
tracking was open th teams offline
right I mean you still need a remote
storage service either way I guess I'm
not understanding question but let me
move on i behold me the topic I wanted
to cover we can take more questions at
the end so so let me let me just get
into it and an interest of time and this
work was about cloud computing security
and of course you know cloud computing
is going to have is going to be quite
the consumer of cryptographic services
it already is so we're interested in
what types of threats exist in this
context and whether there's really new
threats that come up here or if there's
kind of the same old issues so what is a
cloud community service well we were
focusing on so-called infrastructures of
service systems you have a provider that
has a bunch of physical hosts with a
virtualization layer running on top of
it users can come and pay the the
provider to run their their
computational tasks in the the sense of
running virtual machines on their
service they're quite dynamic so you can
start and stop virtual machines it will
start them up again and an important
facet of and feature of these types of
clouds is the the use of multi-tenancy
that simply put users are sharing
physically physical resources and of
course it is important from the
providers point of view because then
they can statistically multiplex their
physical resources across a wide user
base and get economies of scale that way
so again this is powered by
virtualization so each physical server
has a virtual machine a hypervisor a
virtual machine manager hypervisor
running on it and the idea is that this
should provide the appearance of having
a dedicated machine to oneself so we're
interested in the following hypothetical
threat that lies at the intersection of
this use of multi tense through the fact
that these clouds are public that anyone
can start running virtual machines on
them and so the idea is the following
that an attacker is going to identify
one or more victims running in the cloud
and then try to exploit what we call a
placement foreigner ability so for
example the attacker could launch lots
of virtual machines and have each of
these checks somehow for Co residents on
the same server as the victim and should
this be successful now the attacker can
mount the tax to take advantage of this
close physical proximity so you could of
course exploit some known VMM
vulnerability and then just take over
the whole box and kinda have a target
wait and use a known vulnerability you
could also do denial of service attacks
so degrade you know use up resources
trying to grade the the efficiency of
the victim and then the perhaps most
subtle threat would be that of physical
side-channel attacks which is that just
the fact that you're sharing the same
resources resources cache memory hard
disks might be sufficient already to
extract some confidential information
out of the out of the victim so this is
a you know a hypothetical threat we were
curious to see if it's actually a real
threat so we did a case study with
Amazon ec2 service and what were able to
do despite you know being white hat
researchers and abiding by the
acceptable use policy of Amazon service
we're never less able to do the
following engage in what we call cloud
cartography so this is mapping out some
if not all the internal infrastructure
of the service with particular and being
that given a target a public IP address
we can locate approximately where in the
infrastructure this target is running
and in particular identified launch
parameters that would be advantageous
for malicious virtual machines to be to
be ran under to try and end up on the
same physical server as as the victim
learn how to do co residents checking so
actually understanding when you're
successfully on the same physical server
and then we did measurements to
experiment experiment measurements to
see if this is you know this is
frequently achievable and and it is and
so the problem is that of course this
already reveals a placement boner
ability that that attackers can
knowingly achieve co residents with with
a victim this is dangerous for a bunch
of reasons we were particularly
interested in this aspect of physical
side-channel attacks and we're able to
show cross vm side-channel attacks that
that can spy on the momentary load
computational load of a victim so i'll
talk about each of this in a bit more
detail now but first let me give a very
high level overview of some of the
instance networking of ec2 so you have
virtual machines running on on within a
virtual machine manager each virtual
machine has associated to it an external
IP address an internal IP address
conveniently from attackers point of
view the internal dns service
in AC to actually maps an external IP
address query to it by any party to the
internal IP address associated to it and
this is i think is to encourage people
to communicate via internal IP addresses
within the cloud this is they priced
differently and it's more efficient for
amazon presumably our experiments
indicated that the internal IP addresses
are statically assigned to physical
servers so each machine for example
hosting the smaller type of instances
ends up having eight contiguous internal
IP addresses associated to it and in
fact the the way they did their
networking actually provided in
hindsight a very simple way of doing the
core essence check and we did a lot of
work to establish that this this works
but in the end it's simple you can just
do a traceroute to a target internal IP
address or a public IP address and if
you only have one hop then then you know
you're on the same box because what
happens is the vm m actually routes to
the traffic right back to the to the
guest operating system so with that in
mind we know how to occur aizen's
checking but how do we actually kind of
figure out where in the cloud a victim
is and how can we understand how to get
to that portion of the cloud so what we
did is this measurement study that we
call cloud cartography so we identified
the launch parameters for virtual
machines in the ec2 service so for
example this includes things like the
availability zone which are advertised
is disjoint portions of the internal
infrastructure for redundancy purposes
the type of virtual machine instance
requested and is just a varying levels
of virtualized resources that are handed
to the virtual machine and then of
course things like user account are also
identified so what we did is is run
using an account under our control
virtual machines and change each of
these parameters one at a time so here
we have a graph of the internal IP
addresses of the resulting virtual
machine instances colored by the
requested availability zone and so what
this shows is that the internal IP space
is segregated according to availability
zone which makes sense in light of what
they're advertising blue zones to be
used for
can repeat this for instance types here
we have a bunch of virtual machines that
we ran that are colored by the instance
type and again we see quite a bit of
regularity in terms of which portions
the internal IP address space are being
used by which types of instance and then
this bottom half of the chart is is
using a second account and we end up in
the same portions of the internal IP
address space and in fact ended up with
the same internal IP address many times
so we can take this idea kind of logical
conclusion and basically provide a map
now that associates for example to each
/ 24 so the first three octet some an
internal IP address an estimate of the
availability zone and an instance type
that we think are running on that chunk
of IP addresses and so this proves quite
useful because then given a set of
public IP addresses for example we can
map all those two internal IP addresses
using the internal ec2 dns and and then
just look at the first three octet to
get an estimate of the availability zone
in distance type and this is just a
chart showing colorings of a bunch of
public HTTP servers that we're running
at the time of the study with the point
being that we get quite a good coverage
across the internal IP address space so
okay so now we know how to locate
approximately the cloud where we're a
victim is and we know it specifically
what launch primers would be good for us
to use and so that now that we've kind
of narrowed the search down can we
actually get on the same physical server
with with good frequency and so we did a
bunch of different experiments to assess
the likelihood of this and I'll just
tell you about one of them and the
setting here is that we are able to
launch the attack virtual machines
relatively near in time to when the the
victim was launched and so we didn't
experiment where you launch a target
virtual machine and then you launch from
another account a few minutes later just
20 quote-unquote attack virtual machines
and these all these did was check to see
if they're co-resident with the target
and so out of 10 trials this already
succeeds forty percent of time so
immediately you end up on the same
physical server as as the victim and
this is actually very cheap you know at
the time it was to yes dollars i think
it's gone down since then
electrochem the same client
other words the same wifey address yes
uh for these experiments no I change
between different IP addresses i mean
it's from the same UC san diego domain
so they could be we didn't exhaustively
experiment i also did some launches from
home it seems that they're not taking
that into account of course they could
but my sense is that they're not and of
course there are some portions of the
ec2 infrastructure that we don't have
access to I mean they have large
corporate clients that maybe get some
portion privately but for this kind of
public portion of the cloud it seems
that you can really get on the same
system so we we did use for example
there are some free demos from some
companies that use ec2 service so they
had like a Collin cloud appliances or
something and you can launch a free demo
using their web interface under there so
it's their account and we were able to
achieve code residents with those as
well ok so what can you do once you are
end up on the same physical server well
we experimented with this idea of
physical side-channel attacks in
particular showed how to do across vm
load measurement using CPU cache
contention so the idea that a high level
is straightforward you have an attacker
and a victim virtual machine on the same
cpu architecture and so what the
attacker does is first read in a large
array of data to basically ensure that
he uses the entire CPU cache and then
the attacker idle loops with the idea
that this will allow the victim to run
hopefully on the same a cache
architecture and if the victim is you
know has computational load it's going
to use up some portion of the cash for
its own purposes and so when the
attacker runs again he can now measure
the time to read in this large array and
this becomes load measurement and the
point is that it's going to be
correlated quite strongly with the
amount of cash usage by the victim and
consequently the amount of CPU load that
the victim is is currently under
I'll the Train Christian about how these
side-channel attacks are we are we
worried about private keys disappearing
or we work out to the core stuff because
load that they load I can confirm I just
cooking at the victims HTTP server and
see how late it is anyway and so by the
fish's house how scary is threatening if
we cook at this for another another 10
years we get in getting so so yeah my
sense is that I don't know and I think
in general the there needs to be a lot
more research on the side channel tax
basically they're all kind of a black
art at this point you know you have
someone sit down some grad student who
has not enough free time on their hands
and figures out how to do an attack for
a particular architecture and privilege
of setting and the granularity there is
basically depends on a lot of different
factors how many cores your float
floating between how many how much noise
is on the system and we don't really
have good tools as far as i can tell of
quantifying this type of attacks i think
it's a great open research question the
concern of course which i'll talk about
is that these these attacks that we used
are based on the side channels that in
non virtualized settings were able to
extract a s Keys across process
boundaries in certain settings so
there's looming concern that yeah as you
get a more refined attacks then you're
going to be pulling out more and more
dangerous confidential information mas
may not be a huge threat in the future
because we'll have an AS architectural
chip for you know on Intel Architecture
will have an AAS instruction but the
problem with side channels are difficult
to close down stairs the getting
information ticular yeah
information then there's how I actually
get information clan channel attacks
were probably very are pathetic always
be there right with this ability to
target do you think that this is
important I mean Amazon's policemen
algorithms were optimized for been
packing repression see relatively small
cluster so in the same way that you used
to be able to check information p
streams use predictable send sequence
numbers decided that was the idea we
started randomized webinar we're just
going to make this co residency possible
future so the fact is if you're doing
multi-tenancy co residency is not
impossible right if you're sharing
physical servers between mutually
untrusted parties can you make it
arbitrarily I think it's a machine it's
initially difficult so so certainly yeah
sorry finisher yeah can I make cars
really do difficult the chief residency
particular target you can't make it are
actually difficult if you don't allow
someone else to get on that box I mean
so there's one way to make it possible
which is to shut down multi chance right
which is actually something we suggest
is as the only surefire solution here I
think if you if you allow if you lab
multi-tenancy the question is can you
make it arbitrarily hard I don't know
it's a good research question I think
you could close down all a lot of the
things that we took advantage of like
network configuration issues right but
that's only going to slow and attacker
down right so it's a good question i
don't know whenever you have multi
chance you have the potential for
getting on the same box and you have
side channels so it's something we need
to think about and the point of the
research were saying look that there is
this new aspect in cloud computing right
where you have this first step you you
have to get onto the box first before
you can take advantage of close physical
proximity and so is this something
that's realizable well it turns out yes
can we defend against it it's an open
research question yeah
okay so applications across vm load
measurements so we can do things like
measure relative traffic rates across
virtualization boundaries so for example
we set up an Apache server and a attack
vm that was co-resident running ec2 and
then we just buried the level of traffic
sent to the the blue server here and the
bar chart on the right reveals the the
vm i'm sorry the load measurements that
were taken by the attacker and so we see
the strict differentiation of load
measurement and so information is
certainly leaking here across boundaries
yep
I mean in a abstraction so led much load
measurement here is is the read time
from that third step in the algorithm
and so it could it could be a bunch of
different features but the point is that
you can correlate it to other things
that are happening with the with the box
right not understanding what the it is
correlate what so here it's the relative
traffic rates right so you know that if
you saw in this in this granted
experimental setting right you see
higher levels of load measurements you
know there's more activity going on more
HTTP HTTP requests occurring Oh oh these
are this is a this is the mean cpu cycle
right to load the array in the 37
experiment this happens to be a metric
where you're going to have a strong
correlation between memory use some cpu
use because he used boise retain yeah
but so it's so right right a memory so
so this doesn't seem like the right it
seems like if you're only using this
test you're getting the wrong you
measuring the wrong thing is it for what
exactly so so so for some applications
yeah maybe you're not hitting the cash
as much and then you won't get any
signal even though you have cpu load
right well that's the exact problem that
like a s does use the cash right and so
that's where we get issues with a s
side-channel attacks across process
boundaries which could end up being a
problem here so I mean yeah I mean you
do use the cash for lots of different
things the question maybe there are some
things that are literally only in
registers on the on the cpu proper and
not using the l1 cache or the l2 cache
at all and then you then you wouldn't be
able to measure those type of behaviour
you're right so it's a cash load
measurement I guess would be
I'm just sitting in here you can see how
much you're just looking at you good
schedule so it is it is court yeah so
you'll see that if other instances are
busy for example you'll get floated more
frequently in between cores and stuff so
these are other ways that information is
leaking across that doesn't take
advantage of the cash I mean the point
yeah I mean this is just one example
where we said okay here's a proof of
concept in ec2 we can get information
leaked across virtualization boundaries
right we can get on the same box and
when then we can do it now it you know
maybe this isn't the most damaging thing
to be learning in the first place but
it's something you shouldn't be learning
the virtualization is supposed to be
stopping this type of leakage or at
least that's the concern that people
think that this is the case and so you
know in general there's going to be a
whole wide range of side channels that
you might be able to take advantage of
we also looked at you know taking care
of memory contention hard disk
contention of course I was talking to
someone about network card contention
then that and they are saying oh yeah
this seems like a great way to get in a
good position to take advantage now work
hard contention to identify encrypted
streams and these types of things so
they were so there's a lot of different
ways you could kind of play as an
attacker with with various shared
resources once you're on the box I mean
you still look confused but maybe we can
talk about later running a long time
yeah okay so you know we show how things
East you like setting a keypress timing
you could kind of do this and get even
finer grain information of course the
future work is the concern is about AAS
cryptographic keys or other
cryptographic keys being taken across
virtual machines we think this is a big
problem you know talking to people in it
at certain companies and others they
seem to agree this is an issue that
people should be concerned about there's
a lot of potential countermeasures we
could look at but you know this is open
research question about what are the
trade-offs and whether you can even
quantifiably come up with any resistance
to side-channel attacks it's an open
open problem let me just finish off very
quickly was saying a bit about my future
work and I think you know I cast cloud
computing stuff in a negative light in
the last bunch of slides but actually
the project made me quite excited about
cloud computing in general that that you
know really looking forward we can kind
of see that this is going to take off it
has a lot of value added for customers
and we're going to end up in a world
where a lot of competition pass if not
the majority are going to end up being
done with clouds and sometimes we're
going forward we're also going backwards
you know we had long ago many-to-one
systems where he had shared many frames
with many users sharing one single
computer and we had this personal
computing revolution with kind of
one-to-one mapping and now with cloud
c'mere we have this now many users
sharing a heterogeneous distributed
infrastructure save this many-to-many
mapping and with this with this change
you know we have lost security challenge
looming we identified one but there's
others and I want to understand these so
for example I think investigating more
how the mismatch of our legacy abstract
and so how engineers have been designing
software now for the one-to-one personal
computing era really have mismatches
with the current realities of running
these things in cloud computing settings
and understanding this is going to give
rise to further security vulnerabilities
now I think another interesting line of
work is about understanding whether we
can do cryptographic auditing of cloud
services so the idea is that right now
cloud services are quite opaque from a
user's point of view and they want to
have guarantees about the their data and
their services and so can we even
provide technical mechanisms that could
complement any contractual mechanisms to
audit you know for example that a cloud
is truly using enough redundancy for our
data for example and then finally in a
bit farther out there I think that you
know we saw with the move from many two
one two one two one person commune we
had this kind of revolution in a lecture
on a crime and I think it's interesting
to at least start thinking about what
type of repercussions moving to this new
setting is going to have on the the
underground economies that are current
going out there whether we can get ahead
of this is one question but also just
understanding and measuring electronic
crime is a considerable challenge and
something I think is fascinating we're
motivated by the computing model for me
for instance
computers are just by the fact that it
got a whole lot bigger and so there's a
lot more opportunity does it I mean from
a crime point of view I guess doesn't
matter exactly the motivation was the
point was that having wanted one
personal computing a kind of enabled
this new wave of crime right yeah so in
some sense from more people using it but
then we'll see a similar explosion the
more people be using a variety of new
services because of cloud computing and
so similar effects might be going on so
you know yeah lastly before I finished
just want to thank of course all my
collaborators without them this work
would've been possible and at this point
i guess i'll just take questions thank
you
yeah thank you very much